today I'm gonna be talking about
plotting massive data sets on your
laptop and specifically using SQL
engines for that so this is a really
simple and elegant solution that you can
apply
um without having to worry about much
big machines or clusters okay so let's
get started I'm gonna skip this one
since I was already introduced so let's
go to the next slide okay so first
um the usual let's imagine you have a
large data set and by large it actually
depends on how big your machine is right
but it can be somewhere between 10 20
Gigabytes what would you do with this
data set usually what we do is we load
this data with pandas or numpy
maybe we are using a Jupiter lab so we
load the data we are on a notebook we
load the data we make a few
Transformations and then we use
matplotlib to generate some charts maybe
we are interested in plotting some
histogram or a box plot or a scatter
plot
um matplotlib offers all these different
plots that we can use now what's the
problem with this traditional approach
the problem is that since we are loading
all the data into memory at once we can
start getting into memory issues pretty
rapidly especially because if we are
using pandas and we make a few
Transformations on our data we might be
creating copies of it without us
noticing like depending on the
operations that we apply to your data
frame you might be creating copies so
you love let's say you load these large
CSV file and let's assume these white uh
box is the ram the memory that you have
available on your machine so you create
a first copy and maybe you apply a new
transformation and you create a second
copy and then you apply another
Transformations and now you have another
copy so soon you'll have multiple copies
of your data and your machine and the
moment you start um trying to apply more
Transformations or or plotting this data
you may run out of memory right so at
this point if you start to have some
memory issues you may think well maybe I
should bring um
larger machine right so that's kind of
the first solution that you may think if
these 16 gigabyte laptop is not enough
maybe I need more memory so maybe I can
just use some ec2 machine on AWS get a
32 gigabyte or 64 gigabyte machine
and just plot my data there well that's
that's actually a reasonable solution
but you have to get this machine you
have to pay for it and it complicates
things because now you have to get this
new machine spin up the the instance
then make sure that you have your code
and your data in that machine so it
creates many extra steps for you just to
create this simple plot
another solution and even more more
complex solution might be well I'm I'm
gonna use a cluster I'm gonna use a
distributed framework distributed
computing framework and then this
framework will take care of plotting my
data right because distributed computing
Frameworks make sure that you distribute
the the workload in many machines so
this big data set May split into
multiple smaller parts and then each
part can be assigned to a separate
machine this is an even more complex
solution and it requires so many extra
steps because first you have to make
sure that you have a closer available to
you you have to make sure that you have
a distributed framework that can process
the data in parallel so it's too many
extra steps right so what I'm going to
propose in this talk is that you can get
away with a really simple solution for
moderately large data sets and this will
also depend on how your data is and how
much memory you have available but in
many cases this is a create effective
solution
so what I'm proposing here is that we
can use an embedded SQL engine so let's
talk about embedded SQL engines a SQL
engine is defined is is explicitly
designed to perform computation
sufficiently so I'm sure you have used
any a SQL database before or like a
warehouse like snowflake redshift or a
more traditional database like Oracle
postgres MySQL all of those are
optimized to perform computations
efficiently right they they manage and
they come up with a plan to compute
whatever you want to compute you
essentially if you have your SQL you
know that you declare certain
Transformations on the data maybe you
want to group by some column maybe you
want to compute some statistics like
percentiles or you want to take them in
those kinds of things you only specify
the Transformations that you want to
apply and then the SQL engine figures
out how to do it and it makes sure that
you don't run out of memory so
essentially you are offloading these
manipulation logic to the SQL engine who
was specifically programmed to do this
to do these computations efficiently
so they are really memory efficient now
of course if you are using something
like postgres you have to install
postgres you have to create a database
you have to upload data into the
database and then you can start running
queries on it that's why
we have these embedded SQL engines an
embedded SQL engine is a much simpler
engine that you can that you can use as
an alternative and it doesn't require
any setup but you only have to set up a
server you don't have to create a
database it's an a SQL interface that
allows you to perform computations in a
single machine
so there are the two most popular
embedded SQL engines are sqlite and drb
so sqlite
um I'm pretty sure you are running many
sqlite databases without you knowing uh
for example your phone
um many application applications on your
phone run sqlite and the data is managed
in a sqlite database
sqlite is a great alternative because it
comes pre-installed with python so if
you have python on your computer you
already have sqlite you don't have to
install any extra dependencies or
anything you can start running queries
with SQL by using sqlite
dog DB is a more recent project and is
specifically designed for running
analytical queries
and it stores the data in a column based
Manner and it the most interesting part
of this is that it can run queries
directly on a CSV or parquet files and
other formats you simply correct your
SQL point to the file the data file that
you want to run queries
like a CSV file and then you can start
running any kind of analytical queries
so those two are the ones that I I have
experience with and both of them are
great of course stock DB is a lot more
optimized for these analytical queries
but you can also
um use SQL like for um some moderately
large data sets
so here I have two code examples just so
you know how how it looks like in
practice
with sqlite as I mentioned before you're
going to have to install any extra
dependencies it already comes
pre-installed with python so you can
start a python session do import sqlite
tree and then you can create a
connection to a database
then you can upload the data to your
database and there are some commands
that you can use for example to import a
CSV file into a DOT DB file which is the
format that sqlite uses
and then you can start running queries
so you see I'm running here I'm calling
the execute method and I'm passing this
SQL command and then I can get the
results
and sqlite is taking care of
manipulating the data transforming the
data I don't have to worry about memory
because uh sqlite is doing that for me
here doc TV is pretty similar to get drb
up and running I have to do pip
install.db but it's really simple it
doesn't take much effort to get it open
running
then I can connect to a database like
this for example here I'm connecting to
an in-memory database so I'm telling
docdb to store all my all the data and
all the transform data sets that I'm
going to be using in memory maybe
because I only want these
Transformations I don't want to store
them on disk I just want them
temporarily
and same idea I can start running
queries on my data now what's
interesting about docdb is that I can do
a select star from
and then pass a CSV file
and then here I can maybe select a few
columns maybe I can Group by and dogdib
is going to take care of loading that
CSV file and then do the manipulations
it's going to be a much more efficient
way to load and manipulate data than if
I load the entire data set with pandas
and I start doing some manipulations
okay so now let's talk about how we can
use these embedded SQL engines for
plotting and the first use case that I
have is a box plot
let's say we want to create a box like
this and let's focus on only the first
one just to simplify things
what do we have to do to our data set to
plot this box plot well we need a few
statistics right we have the median here
we also need a 25th percentile here we
needed 75th percentile here and we also
have to Define this confidence interval
and the cutoff for the outliers right so
anything that's below this cutoff will
appear here anything above the cutoff
will appear here that's the only thing
we need actually so once we compute
those statistics we can create the Box
Loop so actually let me show you how
matplotlib does that so we are going to
look at matplotlibs source code
very quickly
okay so we are looking at matplotlibs uh
source code here and there's a function
called uh called box plot stats and as
you can see in the description it says
return a list of dictionaries of
Statistics used to draw a series of box
box and whisker plots using and then the
name of the function that you use for
plotting it takes us an argument our
data so this is a vector of numbers and
then it has a few parameters we can
ignore this just to simplify things
and then I'm gonna I'm not gonna go into
the details I just want you to see
what's kind of the logic here remember
that X is our data
so you're essentially uh doing some
Transformations on our data here and we
are Computing some um numbers here the
final dictionary is this stats
dictionary and for example one of the
stats that we need is the mean right so
we take them in for data we also need
the median and the quartiles so that's
what what we do here with numpy and we
get the q1 the median and Q3 we also
need the interquartile range so we
compute it here
then we also compute a few extra things
and at the end of the function we return
a dictionary that contains these
statistics
now as I mentioned before in order for
us to execute this function and actually
when we use matplotlib to create a box
plot
this is the code that's running
so it loads all our data into memory to
compute those statistics and then it
uses the second function called bxp
let me open it
and this bxp takes the dictionary
that we computed before right so we
essentially it's like a two-step process
first we compute the stats
and then
we use this bxp function that takes
those statistics and then creates the
plot
this block
so now to make this more efficient and
to be able to generate box plots for
larger data sets we are going to
substitute
the first part so instead of calling box
plot stats
we are going to implement our own
function that uses SQL and docdb to
compute those statistics
compute the statistics and then call the
second function bxp
to draw the plot
so that's the stadium
now this is um make us really like a
summary of how this could look like I
have an open source implementation and
I'll show the link at the end this is
just so you know kind of how it looks
like we saw that we have to compute a
few statistics one of those statistics
are percentiles right we need 25th
percentile the 50 percentile which is
the median and the 75th percentile now
how do we do that we can create a
function
that takes the connection to the
database in this case is going to be a
dog DB database because it implements a
function to obtain the percentiles table
I'm calling this a table but this is
really going to be a CSV file a purchase
file
um and we are going to create that file
through.db
the column this is the column that we
want to use as input to generate the box
plot
and then the press enter this can be 0.5
0.25 0.75 which are the values that we
need
then I have a template
which is is a template that I use to
generate these percentiles that I want
to compute
if if you're if this looks familiar I'm
using Ginger to compute this
so essentially I say render my template
so convert convert this SQL template
into some SQL code that I can run
I pass the table
or the path to the CSV file the column
and the percentile
so once I've run this line I have a SQL
query that I can run on docdb
that's what I do here
and this is where the magic happens
because Dr DB is taking care of loading
that data Computing that percentile
returning me the result and that's it I
don't have to worry about how much
memory I need because log TV is doing
that for me and then I can call this
function multiple times for the 25th
percentile for the median or for the 75
percentile and we can even make things
more efficient and
compute everything in a single um
function call
so that's the idea
um of course we need to compute a few
other a few other statistics but this
kind of gives you a high level idea of
how the code looks like
you create some SQL you run that SQL you
compute those statistics and then you
can use those statistics to create your
plot
now let me show you the Second Use case
a histogram
kind of the same idea right so we have
um let's say we have a huge Vector of
numbers and we want to create a
histogram
what do we need to create this histogram
we only need two things for each bin we
need the size of the beam and the height
right that's all we need once we compute
those pairs um the the size of the bin
and the height then we can plot it
and we can use the bar function for that
so you you start to see a pattern here
right
in order to create a plot we need to
compute some statistics we compute those
statistics with SQL and then we use
those statistics to plot the chart so
these are just two use cases but you can
extend the same logic to others
now the code for the histogram is
actually a lot simpler than for the box
plot because we only we need a fewer
statistics
so I can show you quickly how it looks
like
um and I'm gonna share the the full
implementation so you can play with it
uh this is just a simplified version
so same idea here we have a function
that takes a table as an argument and
remember this is the path to the CSV
file to the data set that we want to use
as input
the column the column that you want to
use to generate the histogram the number
of means
and the connection to the database
so the first thing that we have to
compute is the range so we need the
maximum and the minimum for our
histogram so we need to know the maximum
and the minimum you know data set I
didn't include the implementation of
this function just for to simplify
things but it's the same idea you have
um you are generating some SQL that
returns you the minimum and the maximum
value so you're executing this on the DB
you can actually run this on SQL Lite as
well because it also has a function to
execute to compute the minimum and the
maximum
when you compute the bin size using the
range so taking the max minus the mean
divided by the number of means you
compute the bin size
then you compute the
the counts essentially the height for
each bin with this equal code
and it's the same idea that I uh the
same logic that I showed for the box
plot you execute you render this with
the parameters you have this template
you pass the parameters that you want
you execute that in the database
and then you'd retrieve all the
information that you need for the plot
in this case what you have are the bins
so essentially the start of the bin the
left side of it and the height for each
mean
and then you use Matlock leave
and then you pass the the beans and the
height
and that's it you generated a histogram
without having to load all your data
into memory
let me go to the next slide
okay now I have an open source
implementation for both of these things
so you can use it to look at the code
see it in detail and see how the
implementation looks like and also you
can try it so you can do pip install QP
SQL and you can find a documentation
here github.com
SQL we also want to show you some quick
demos so you can see how it looks like
in practice
okay
so here what I'm doing is
I am loading some data into
um
into adaptive
database so let me hide this for now
yeah so I'm loading some data here
and then I'm I am showing some of the
rows uh this is some sample data set
that I found that contains I think this
is a music store database so it contains
information about albums and sales and
and some extra information
now what I do here
let me come here yeah right here so I
implemented these uh histogram function
that takes the files that you want to
use
in this case my data is splitted across
several files so I have uh 12 files
actually this is this is not the record
music store I'm using a different data
set so this is the New York City yes
this is a New York City Taxi data and
it's
um I think these are one row is a taxi
trip in New York so it's a couple
million actually you have the account
here so it's 4 million rows so you have
three months of data 4.5 million rows
and what I'm doing here is I'm calling
this plot histogram function that
implements the same logic that I just
described and I'm saying look at all
these three files
then go to trip distance column and
create 50 histogram with 50 beans
which is what you can see here and then
it generated the plot for me now I
cannot see much here because we have a
few outliers right so then what I can do
is I can tell docdb to find the 99
percentile
and it returns me uh 18.93 and then I
can tell
um dog DB to create a new data set with
all the values below this cutoff value
so I can see my histogram more clearly
and then I create a new data set and
then I call my function again
plot.histogram
now this data set doesn't contain any
outliers trip distance
equals 50.
and now I can see my histogram and then
I'm printing the memory usage and you
can see that I'm only using 0.3
gigabytes of memory
this is because doc TV is loading the
data Computing the statistics statistics
and then shutting down the process so I
don't use a lot of memory now let me
show you a benchmark the same I'm going
to create the same histogram but using
pandas and matplotlib so same idea same
data set and I'm gonna call this the
histogram function will not leave
directly and I'm loading this as a data
frame
so you can see I have the same problem
at the beginning that I have a field
layer so I cannot see much of my
histogram
then I compute my cutoff value
and then I call the histogram function
again
and I get pretty much the same thing
but look how much memory I'm using I'm
using 1.2 gigabytes of memory
which is a lot more than 0.3 and this is
actually not a large data set so if we
imagine what happens if we have a data
set thing 10 times as larger as this
with docdb it will remain the same just
0.3 gigabytes of data but we plan this
it will blow up the memory and I
probably won't be able to create this
this plot
okay
um so that's it for me I have my contact
information here in case you want to ask
me any questions my email my Twitter
account my LinkedIn and I hope you enjoy
the presentation remember that I have
this open source implementation so you
can go and look it in detail because I
have had to skip some some important
information but um yeah thanks a lot for
watching
thank you very much for giving us this
amazing talk
and we are we still have a few minutes
for questions
anyway
s
so I see one question is it possible to
increase the Computing speed with this
method I I didn't run benchmarks for
Speed I my guess is that the speed would
be comparable once you have the date and
memory because numpy is really efficient
uh but I think it's an interesting
question so maybe it depends on the size
of the data
um you may get some speed UPS um with
the SQL engines although once you have
the data and memory it's a lot faster so
um it's an interesting question I would
have to run some benchmarks I think the
main benefit here is mostly memory that
doc TV and sqlite can manage the the
memory for you
um but yeah I think depending on how
large the data is and what types of
Transformations you do you may get some
speed improvements
foreign
what kind of problem are you resolving
well it's mostly about convenience right
it's a it's a simple solution because if
you try to run
um if you want to run this create these
plots for large data sets uh you either
need a big machine so let's say you want
to stick with pandas and matplotlib
you can either get a beef machine or run
this in a cluster so what I'm proposing
here is to use a simpler alternative
which is wdb or sqlite and this is a lot
simpler than getting some big easy to
instance or configuring a cluster so
it's a a much more powerful way to scale
the analysis using SQL and I think this
is this is just a use case I'm just I'm
plotting data sets but you can extend
this to many other domains like you
don't have to create plots to use
um these powerful SQL engines you can
use them for manipulating your data so
for example if you are having problems
with pandas and memory you can do
everything that you can do with pandas
you can do it with Doc TV so that's also
a powerful alternative if you are having
memory issues with pandas you can use
these SQL engines and and you can
transform larger data sets without
worrying about memory issues